I have a few fun questions and Jason did
put up with these and actually laughed
so he laughed
you did Wow who ruin the most takes
Hobbs
or sha Goodwin know who ruined the most
takes Hobbs or shop Wow
hot ok who's more likely to get it on
the first take
Hobbs or Shawn Hobbs would be a better
wingman Hobbs or shock sure this is that
this is just pretty late Hobbs is just
too big to be a wingman he's just like
the man not the wing got it up who was
faster at leaving their trailer
Hobbs or sha sure who has more hair
Hobbs or sha trick question a lot so now
I'm switching to who wins in a fight
Hobbs in Shaw or Jason Bourne rickston
Brixton law pick got it who wins in a
fight Hobbs in sha Brixton or Deadpool
Brixton Law who wins in a fight Hobbs in
Shaw Brixton or rocky with the rocky
theme music play services alone that's
my guy right um who wins in a fight
Hobbs in Shaw Brixton or John McClane
ooh John McClane no joke I was gonna be
like well joe mcclane don't die cuz you
know he dies hard
so I'd say John McClane wins I
appreciate the honest answers here yeah
I know I'm being honest I got Hobbs in
Shaw Brixton or Bruce Lee Bruce okay
Hobbs in Shaw Brixton Sigourney Weaver
in aliens as Ripley the alien it's all
so good I'm being serious for a second
okay serious
yeah but this was I'm sure a very
physical shoot just for everything you
guys had to do what's the day that you
left set with just the most black and
blue marks
just really feeling like I got the [ __ ]
kicked out of me it was probably on an
eighth day of doing the final sequence
where you know myself Hobbs in short I
having this epic epic fight now and
after we shot it for eight days and
torrential rain I was like ah I just
want to stay in bed okay
my last thing for you I loved the Fast &
Furious franchise and the way that it
just embraces what it is and there's
tons of these over-the-top moments
including in Hobbs and Shaw do you have
a favorite like over-the-top moment in
the franchise yeah there's this moment
where you know sure Hobbs
yeah I'm in this helicopter I'm pulling
on this helicopter I'm pulling the truck
Hobbs has this truck it has the chain in
one hand trucking in a helicopter he's a
pulling them together that is one of the
most incredible cinematic moments of any
film we've ever seen thank you so much
for your time and I really appreciate
indulging me on the other questions